hi I'm Chris Hardwick co-host of Wired
science I'm fake heating my hands on
this because this looks like a space
heater but it's not a space heater this
is actually the yamaha ysp 4000 it's a
single camera speaker system that
produces sound that's so amazing that
you will literally feel like you were
surrounded by an army of sound obviously
for true surround sound you would need
five or more speakers but Yamaha
actually simulates surround sound by
cramming 40 tiny speakers and two
woofers into just one box and then it
uses electronics to actually tailor the
sound to converge all of the sound waves
right on your noodle so you set this
microphone wherever you're sitting in
your room on your couch on your floor on
your bed then the Yamaha audio
calibration program runs and it sort of
sounds like this crazy
sonar ditty something a little weird but
not to worry because what's happening is
the Yamaha is actually figuring out how
sound is bouncing around your room based
on how the microphone picks up the
signals and because the sound is so
targeted to the exact spot that you're
sitting on your couch you really can't
hear it if you're not in that spot so no
one else will suffer through how awesome
you are at Guitar Hero obviously no
single speaker audio system sounds as
good as real surround sound but the
Yamaha sounds better than any other
single cabinet system we've seen and
also it does video there are actually
six inputs in the back for convenience
and capability and just overall quality
of sound it's really hard to beat the
yxp 4000 by Yamaha which is why we gave
it a 9 out of 10 points and the best of
test award and a fall test issue that is
a huge deal of course it will set you
back about 17 under bones but for a true
audiophile like you what is money if not
to satisfy your ears PS it looks like a
robot turd for Wired I'm Chris Hardwick
you